six-year-old taras works on his movement
at a center for children with
disabilities in Kiev
taras has cerebral palsy his mother
Svetlana says she's grateful he can
still come here for therapy despite the
War
I think we're getting him to use his
arms and legs so he can have full
mobility and he can also socialize here
Terrace's grandmother likes to help the
family lives in Kiev but when The
Invasion began they were in their summer
home outside the city Russian forces
took over their Village for a week they
lived in fear
the memories are still painful
but Svetlana says it was taras who gave
them strength
it was very difficult constant
explosions dead people anxiety it may
have seemed as if Tara's didn't
understand anything but he understood
everything he was being so strong
sometimes it felt as if he was the one
supporting us
the war adds to the challenges The
Children Here face the center's director
says it also increases pressure on staff
who are exhausted but have kept the
center running
the whole team stayed and we're all
working mentally we are very tired it's
hard but we work even during the air
sirens and the shelter
since Russia's Invasion this Center has
become even more vital not only for
children in the key region but also for
families who've been forced to flee from
other parts of Ukraine
eight-year-old Dima is going to try
water therapy for the first time it
helps with movements and strength
Dima and his family lived under Russian
occupation for five months in the
eastern city of izum until Ukrainian
forces retook it like Svetlana olena
finds it hard to talk about the past she
just wants to focus on the future and
help her son move forward step by step
this place is really important because
he lost so much time because of the war
outside of Ukraine's big cities such
support for children with special needs
is rare disability can be misunderstood
families often left to cope alone the
invasions made it harder more centers
like this are needed places that offer
care and support and prove that even in
war there can be light
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Keith